he's the artist formerly known as
McLovin and after his breakout
performance in Superbad Christopher
mintz-plasse seemed like he was on the
verge of joining co-stars Jonah Hill and
Seth Rogen on Hollywood's a-list
following it up with acclaim turns in
kick-ass and How to Train Your Dragon
but his popularity with fans somehow
didn't translate into more big-time
roles here's a look at why Hollywood
won't cast Christopher mintz-plasse
anymore
the curse of McLovin ever since 2007
super bad where he obtained the world's
biggest fake ID Christopher mintz-plasse
has been better known by another name
McLovin McLovin
kind of a stupid name is Ed Fogle what
are you trying to be an Irish R&B singer
nearly 10 years later it's still by far
his most memorable role which is fine if
you want to be a cult figure forever but
not so great for the establishment of a
robust and continuing career in
Hollywood the legacy of McLovin has
utterly overshadowed literally every
movie mintz-plasse has made since it's a
fair bet that at least half his fans
don't even recognize him by his real
name turns out that fake ID wasn't so
fake after all he's focused on his music
while Christopher mintz-plasse
definitely enjoys acting he's also a
dedicated musician and his projects on
that front are clearly just as important
to him as being on-screen he's spending
a lot of time these days practicing
performing and recording with his latest
fan Manman which is of course time he's
not spending auditioning for more or
bigger roles in blockbuster Hollywood
movies which is just how he likes it
telling Stereogum quote I would love to
keep balancing the two I think I'm very
lucky and grateful for where I am right
now
that I can do both acting you can work
for three months and not work for six
months so in that time I love the
momentum of music and everything that's
going on the momentum right now is very
musical I kind of just go with the flow
and close doesn't court celebrity Wow
his super bad caps may seem to be
constantly in our faces at every
possible opportunity
Vince Claus has kept a much lower
profile with a media presence that leans
more toward photos of him cuddling with
dogs than mugging for the camera while
it may keep his name out of the tabloids
keeping a low profile in Hollywood isn't
exactly the best career
when it comes to making movies out of
sight is definitely out of mine heard
but not seen Christopher mintz-plasse
has been a go-to guy for DreamWorks
Animation studio ever since he scored
the role of Fishlegs in How to Train
Your Dragon in addition to voicing that
character through three films and a TV
series the actor was also the first call
when they needed a villains voice for
the 2016 Cole's movie sure it's nice
work but being a voiceover actor is just
another way to be pigeonholed
something men club has already had far
too much of the only way I'll ever be
happy is by eating a troll isn't going
to happen six to you trapped in a sitcom
in May 2012 mintz-plasse scored the lead
role in a CBS sitcom called friendly it
seemed like the perfect vehicle to
transition from movies to television but
tragically friendly creator Alan
Kirschenbaum took his own life before
the project premiered and CBS decided
not only to leave the show out of their
lineup but not to even air a single one
of the eight episodes already in the can
the double blow of losing both
Kershenbaum and the show was hard for
men's claws to bounce back from but in
2016 he finally landed another leading
sitcom role alongside Joel McHale and
Stephen Fry on the CBS sitcom the Great
Indoors
unfortunately that show has been panned
by critics and hasn't exactly set the
ratings on fire either Rotten Tomatoes
described the show as one repetitive
formulaic joke which hardly seems to
suit an actor likeness plots who tried
playing against - Edgar boundary-pushing
project hopefully the show gets a lot
better before men sloth gets stuck in a
downward spiral of lowbrow sitcom shirt
firm he can turn it around
part of the reason for Christopher
mintz-plasse is low visibility in
Hollywood is that he seems to prefer
things that way but he still has both
the chops and the connections in the
industry to make a comeback if he wants
to
not even yeah so if he ever decides to
commit completely to acting and to
pursuing more screentime in bigger
movies becoming a star will probably be
as simple as making a few phone calls to
Rogen and the Apatow crew you wanted me
to be my own man what it looks like all
right all right I'll make some calls
yeah fingers crossed
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love you